[Music]
you got to wonder how many hours we
spent on the show attacking the
communist party of china a lot it's a
totalitarian government our leaders
admire it and that ought to make you
very nervous that's been our position
and still as our position probably
always will be on the other hand we want
to be as honest as possible about things
we see so when the chinese government
does something virtuous doesn't happen
much but we're willing to say so
here's what they've done china's
announced it will limit private equity
firms from raising money to buy
residential properties in china why is
that because chinese citizens turns out
need somewhere to live
real estate bubbles are bad for
everybody except of course for a small
number of real estate speculators as the
chinese government put it houses are for
living in not for speculation and that's
a very good point they may have learned
it from watching say the state of
california in california the average
home is now over 800 thousand dollars in
part thanks to speculation and
homelessness is totally out of control
chinese don't want to copy that model
nor do they want a california-style
popular culture one that worships
celebrity over achievement obsessing
over sleazy famous people on social
media
chinese officials announced that is
quote poisoning the minds of the
country's youth can they stop the youth
from worshiping celebrities probably not
but at least they're worried about it
and that's a start they're also by the
way worried about video games in china
online gaming for children in china will
now be limited to three hours a week on
the weekends this is being done the
government says quote to prevent the
addiction to online games is that a
crazy idea well according to a recent
study in this country the average
american kid plays video games for more
than
15 hours a week
a poll from the university of michigan
found that 86 percent of parents believe
their children spent too much time
playing video games apparently the other
14 were paying attention
so it's a legitimate problem what's
interesting is when was the last time
you heard one of our political leaders
even mention
video games
or housing market speculation or
celebrity worship as a problem
now before you respond by saying that
politicians shouldn't be involved in our
personal lives remember that the cdc
already very much is involved in our
personal lives so maybe our government
could take just a moment from bossing us
around to improve our actual lives once
in a while just go ahead and try even if
you fail it will be an improvement at
least we know you notice
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else